snitch on the toast snitch on the toast
snitch on toast snitch on the toast
sniffles hose I'm here guys we've been
talking about this day for so long the
day is here days here but that's me so
long is on the toast know we've been
talking about it for like two months now
right it's just here like I'm sitting in
the chair you're sitting in the chair
you're back I'm from Italy I am how are
you feeling I definitely felt better
I've been having oh yeah I've been
having some illnesses you know just like
that like jetlag stomach you're
acclimating back back to the US boa
otter real water that's really that's
been great yeah I'm feeling good right
now I'm not tired cuz it's like 7
o'clock for me right now no no no like
5:00 got it but actually I've been
pretty fine with jet lag so how was your
trip it was incredible like honestly
like I would totally move there but like
I just couldn't leave Steen's for that
long but if you want to combat you betta
League scenes for two months okay I had
a really hard time with leaving you guys
for that long
like I would like to hear it I face
times Claudia like hysterically crying
because I was home so homesick I think I
do that to you - yeah you did and you
know what it just gave us a pit and like
then come home with your home say yeah I
know but I don't know what to tell you
is just like I wanted to be there I was
having a great time but like I also
wanted my sister's to be there yeah I
can't have it all
you can't have it all but it seems like
you really did have it all you worked
hard you played hard
I really do bat tan you got great pics
yep you just had I didn't gain weight I
just feel like I need to go back that
because it's shocking it's so important
it's so important it's important to like
how you feel on the trip you know well
we're gaining weight it would have taken
weeks I thought I was gaining weight on
the trip so I was like being such a like
sour puss being like I'm so fat what
would body by snitch say yes well body
missing should be like stop eating the
falafel but like then when I got home
and I realized I didn't it was like ooh
girl you're good and now you don't have
to work so hard now that you're home no
I don't well welcome home we are so
happy to have you on the toast we have a
very special show for you today I'm just
gonna give you guys the rundown because
first we have obviously cinch on the
Toshi and I will be delivering the fast
five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast
then we'll be joined by Nastia Liukin
olympian she is everything and I'm so
excited to talk to her
then after Nastya I will be back with
snitch taking all of your questions
because you guys have very intrepid yes
you did a lot of them I don't have
answers to so and we will get to all of
that so fast I've Nastya snitch Q&A and
you know during the past I'd bill just
have to be catching up with snitch
because I'm sure there'll be a story in
there you know I never know I can't
believe you're here I don't feel how do
you feel about the toast what do you
think ok so I was saying - yes you're
like I'm so nervous because like when we
did the be like I don't know I just
didn't really take it seriously he's
like oh the missus used to be morning so
I'm gonna go host it but now I feel like
this is like a real morning show and
like I'm really here and like people
like or like really watching and I'm
really co-hosting and it's like freaking
me to f out so like I'm just very
nervous so bear with me here that's so
crazy that you feel that way I'm so
honored like this is more prestigious so
much more prestigious everyone's talking
about the toast you feel like yeah and
it's just I don't know I feel like that
- yeah it's just it's a different vibe
like this is so much more like you're a
host your host get it together yeah yeah
okay yeah are you ready to fulfill your
hosting duties I am ok you guys we are
about to hit you with the fast five
stories you need to know before you wake
up and take a bite out of your morning
toast a lot of stuff happened yesterday
and we gotta get right to it because
first of all very exciting news out of
New England but the Patriots signed Eric
Decker for one-year deal I'm so happy
about this because like I only know so
many things about football and these are
like the only two things that I know and
they're just coming together so it's
just like hey what else could I ask for
here it's craziness but at first I was
like oh cool now I'm a Patriots fan like
that was a Patriots fan before - what
now Danny Amendola switch so I don't
really know what to think about that
Eric Decker can replace the Danny
Amendola sized hole in the patriot he's
the only person who could and he did I
swear to god I think that like Robert
Kraft like knows like he just needs to
keep it like like he watches him in
Toronto but like he's not just trying to
like get like a great player like he
needs to get someone who's like hot and
like people are gonna love do you donate
me yeah that's their reputation now it
really boosts morale and then you have
like girls like us who are now Patriots
fans
I really hope they go to the Super Bowl
because we'll be there and then we'll
get to see Eric Decker play me people
like be near Jessi and be like oh my god
like have you heard of mourning
you should come on it I feel like she
could totally come on it she could well
we met her at the CMAs and we grabbed
her belly her pregnant belly rubs her
belly with sorry I think she was like
really taken aback yeah that's a shot
that's a really weird thing simple to a
celebrity that you just met is a bullet
move are you hit I don't know to be
determined
anyways this is also a bold move but
it's also a little sad for me because he
joined the Titans and they moved back to
Nashville and it was a dream right and
the families in Nashville dresses in
Nashville making country music and I
think that they thought that they would
be there for a while so I imagine even
though the Patriots is very prestigious
it's a lot of change for the family what
about the kids like their school life I
know that's hard and it's only a
one-year deal so I don't even think that
the kids in the family are gonna move up
nor me neither nor should that I was
going to say that like they shouldn't I
feel like it'll be a lot of flying and
traveling traveling like they can't
handle like the new baby like to move
again like he's been on like every good
team not good but like prestigious like
the Jets like I know they stop but like
New York he's just been on every team
and I don't know if that's a bad thing I
don't know I think it might be coming to
a close at some I mean it's all the
business I did it say how much his deed
his one-year deal is gonna cost him I
have a feeling it's not that much and
that's probably why they did it also
because I keep it's the prestige of Eric
Decker - like but I wonder if Robert
Kraft even like puts that into
consideration
I feel like about all of the team owners
he does not like really doesn't give a
damn I've said it once and I'll say it
again but I've never said it on a
platform this big the Patriots are the
Kardashians of football and he knows
that I love you talking about how big
this platform is cuz like I'm just as I
think you understand Lee I understand
severity I do I really do min-joon so
this is just boding well for football
season
are you watching oh you know I am yeah
and now you're a big Pats fan I was a
pad to him before work because what else
would we be we have nothing here and yet
be proud actually I think technically
the Giants are considered a good team
but I'm just I don't care about them I
don't care about them I don't I just I
try I just like hot players
I like the Jets more than the giant me -
you can't say that yeah I don't think so
you can't say that though like people
don't support that viewpoint why that's
like saying like the Mets more than the
Yankees
no but like everyone loves an underdog
at least the Jets like
Mark Sanchez who brought us Kate Upton
who was God's gift to this world I'm Pro
Jets can you explain that they like
dated and because they were dating
that's how she got on the cover of
Sports Illustrated I think that's how
people knew her oh and now we have this
gift this voluptuous gift this
voluptuous gift and loving and for that
I will always thank Mark Sanchez and the
Jets okay I mean I mean I like the Jets
more than thank you for your service
Mark Sanchez dy ah yeah the Giants just
like do absolutely nothing for me like
those Manning brothers I see on the
Giants and one of them oh one retired
and he's like unreal right yeah he did
like great stuff Peyton was painting yet
every life le like le I mean in Jewish
wedding it's on the Giants Eli Manning
is on the guy thing let's go with that I
don't know it's always in flux at one
point he was on Giants let's just say
that okay but and you know we don't have
enough time in today's schedule to wait
for the viewer comments to correct us
Ellie's on the job you know he's on the
Giants I've been in it for too long
anyways I'm happy for the Decker family
the Kraft family the Brady family Brady
oh yeah great family Josh my family is
just happy for all the families involved
as well okay but not the Amendola family
we need to talk about it no I know that
Danny Amendola like I can't lie like
Olivia Cobo now being like in bathing
suits all the time but they're in Austin
he's no he's Miami Dolphins
no but he's living in Austin I
understand but when it seems like the
football season she's gonna be in Miami
all the time I guess and then it's gonna
be like premium premium content but she
accepted wearing Patriots gear is just
like so cool now that like she was cool
but maybe he'll make Miami cool yeah
that's a great it's an easy City to make
cool that's true okay speaking of family
Kim Kardashian calls sister Courtney the
least exciting to look at during an epic
fight on Keeping Up with the Kardashians
so yesterday a bunch of clips were
released in promotion of Sunday's
episode of Keeping Up with the
Kardashians
oh it's this Sunday yeah I cannot wait I
never really watched religiously but I'm
gonna this I always like gets so excited
for the premiere and then I fizzle out
because there's not much there there but
this episode
it's crazy so basically Kourtney and Kim
are fighting because Kim's organizing
the Christmas photo shoot and Kourtney
is not being flexible with her schedule
because she doesn't want to like work
that much and wait around and do photo
shoots and Kim like just well also in
honor yes but also a prompt day which
would also prompt me was like Kim had a
meeting at 4:00 and she liked how to do
it at this time and she was like if I
can't do it then then I'd have to have
this meeting at 7:00 in the morning and
Kourtney was like so have it at 7:00 in
the morning like who wasn't meeting at
7:00 in the morning like that's so
unrealistic and then that's when Kim
flipped and I just want to say like I'm
so so team Kim she was really she was
really rude she was really [ __ ] and
she was really like cruel to her but
like Kourtney needed to hear it I'm
sorry she just goes on these lavish
vacations she doesn't do [ __ ] literally
doesn't move like I honestly don't know
what she does on a day-to-day basis she
like works out and then lays down like I
don't know and they came and Kylie and
even Chloe are busting their ass every
five seconds like and she like can't do
a photoshoot at four o'clock in the
middle of the day because she just
doesn't want to because and then you get
mad that Kim is yelling at you when Kim
literally gave you that the life that
you have right
I just don't know Kim gave you the
luxury to choose when you work also like
it's so interesting she can give you the
luxury of getting paid to stand and take
a picture no and it's like also like I
wish my problems were like there's a
photo shoot and I don't want to do it
like right must be nice but I just I
just I really it made me and also what I
appreciate is like that Kim says what
we're all thinking that like Kourtney's
not doing it but and it's like I didn't
even know I was thinking that but yes I
guess I didn't know that I was thinking
that either I guess technically Kourtney
would be the least exciting to look at
everybody that is such if you said that
to me like I would be like actually
heartbroken like that's evil no but like
she didn't say that she's ugly or
anything cuz she's not she's beautiful
but like the rest of them are so like
interesting they're like caricatures of
wind yeah and honestly some people might
take it as a compliment that Kourtney is
least excited because the rest of them
are like not real people but yeah that
was shot I know but Kim saying that
Kourtney like doesn't work and it just
doesn't ever work ethic and until she
does she can't call the shots like here
for it needed to be said they did to be
here letting off the fruits of the land
you need to you need to plow plow the
land sure I also just can't believe that
like actually you know what I completely
forgot what I was gonna say and I one
more thing to say even though I'm
totally team came on this mostly because
even if the game was around I could
still be team came over Courtney
Courtney as my favorite Kardashian I
don't even follow her on instead what I
was gonna say but they're talking about
the Christmas photo shoot which we all
saw and it was 25 shitty ass photos that
were literally all taken in one day of
them standing around in jeans and
t-shirts and Kim's acting like she's
planning like the greatest photo shoot
of all time like a Renoir painting when
it was absolute trash uninteresting not
cool candid stupid and came talking
about it like it's the greatest thing
since sliced bread and they're working
so hard on it
no they literally could have showed up
for one hour taking 25 candid photos and
then they cut up the photos yes show
only some family I didn't put it
together that that was the photo shoot
like I knew that it was the Christmas
one but I forgot what the Kristen Simoes
one was because it was so like not
rememberable I mean actually the
Christmas photo shoot like really made
me mad at the Kardashians like if you go
back to old episode I stood up too much
if they just come out within like
whatever like fine okay I was a bad
photo shoot but they were like making it
like this big deal I was expecting oh
we've got to be like 25 yet they would
reveal the pregnancies or something and
there was nothing and their old photo
shoots which was just like the family
around the staircase they did so many
cool things like those were iconic like
this was not by the way those old
Christmas card like the ones I got Sarah
please give me such dynasty vibes no
it's [ __ ] everything everything but
what I was gonna say earlier that I
forgot is that I didn't know that I
hated Courtney so much she would have
been up there with like cuz I was
thought she was like funny like low-key
until this whole thing happened now I
actually despise her she's at the bottom
my list like Rob is before her no I
don't know me they're like on par
honestly but I always say Courtney's my
least favorite I just don't like her
attitude she talks way too slow says
absolutely nothing absolutely no I'm
like now I don't even I just I don't
relate to her actually I kind of do Rick
cloudy and I were talking about this no
later cuz it's like I don't wanna do
anything I don't want to live off the
fruits of the land oh so I get it but
when someone puts me in my place I'm
like yeah you're right Claudia and I
were talking about like who in our
family is who in the Kardashians and
there's no equal no there's not except
that was Olivia and like you
and Kendall probably except Kendall's
like annoying and they're kind of like
doesn't really like have personality but
like I'll take that with the like to get
compared I was watching an episode
yesterday where they go to st. Bart's
and like Kendall is being so goddamn
annoying about Kylie like hanging out
with her and it's like [ __ ] you're the
one who's never and I like Kylie is home
all the time ready to hang out with you
and what there you go on a trip for five
days and you meet her up your ass I
remember that it wasn't she was so mad
that I got there and it was like it's
you're just upset that you don't have a
boyfriend like your little sister is has
her boyfriend with you like in say with
her in st. Barths and you're mad that
she's not hanging out with you like what
do you expect I she know we're doing and
like oh god I can't
anyways but we were talking about who's
who and I do have some Kourtney elements
to me we all have some Kourtney elements
to yes just like that
she's like the least like emotional like
very like you know wait did you see
there was another clip that wasn't the
fight but it was like I don't know if he
was post fight whatever where they're
talking on the couch is and and Kourtney
is dead silent like not saying anything
he's like him and like Khloe are like
toying with her whatever like to be like
hi like we're here and she was like what
do you want to do just sit and stare and
it was like so rude
like she cleared and then when they were
like that she was coming over and they
were like I'm so afraid of her we would
do that like if one of us was like being
[ __ ] like that we yeah and like we'd
like I'll come so scared but none of us
have ever been like that [ __ ] and like
oh we've never like that's additional
only [ __ ] have like someone that comes
at us but we don't just like show up to
a conversation like [ __ ]
and like making fun of your home
furniture and what that was so mean also
is about the reference of the furniture
like they're mean to each other on a
whole other on a whole other level and
they're mean took Kris on a whole other
level and it's like maybe it's for TV
also when Kourtney and Kim were fighting
like Kim it almost look like she was
smiling and that made me feel like they
were acting a little bit ok well but the
fight was way too real it went and like
cutting for it to be fake but when
Kourtney was like on the phone crying
and Kim was like laughing like I was
laughing like I know that's so mean to
say you can't like laugh at your sister
crying but it was just like funny was
the whole thing she was saying such
weird things yeah like the whole thing
she was like I'm focused on being a mom
that's when Kim started laughing as if
they're not focused on motherhood yeah
no totally
no you can do both you can do both not a
woman can do both and she's really
focused on like
buying organic deodorant and making sure
her kids like going to BC number when
she did that but came line to DC to
right I mean I came actually did
something that's true Courtney did
something I did she add amount anyways
you need more Kylee bring back our Kiley
and everything will be okay I just I
need less kind of Lenin ethos Courtney
and the two of them together are
actually the words they've been super
buddy-buddy on social media lately and
it's making me hate Kendall I mean I
already don't like Kendall yeah but I
hate Courtney less more okay next story
something that I called yesterday new
Orange County housewife Gina Gershon
Haider opens up about filing for divorce
so like I said seemed like Gina went on
the show to get a divorce so that she
had a career when she was on her own and
I've been proven right yet again so I
think this story just goes to show the
morning toes is in tune with what's
necessary and I don't appreciate you
using my television time to get a
divorce like do it before or do it after
well after not during because that's not
fun to watch someone going through a
divorce and I'll watch it Shannon go
through and I'll watch Kelly go through
because I love them now
but I don't know you I don't know you
from Adam yeah why do I need to watch
your divorce yeah that's weird
I don't want you're not a housewives
person cuz your cuz cuz you're not a
millennial is that why I can't even
totally missed the mark on all that but
I'm in too deep like I can't I just
can't do it now I really wish I did do
you watch any Bravo shoes I remember I
watched lycra Honi like in the beginning
like with you guys like when we were in
high school we'd like watch it together
but like that it just like I don't know
I just stopped
I really do watch any Bravo shows like I
appreciate Bravo if that makes sense
like I love Indy coming and like I love
all the people in like a la la like I
get it but like I just don't watch it
but I were to watch one it would be the
under bomb totally like from the
beginning yeah you should and you should
maybe like one day also southern charm
is great too but I don't know if you
have the patience for it I don't think I
do you don't have patience for much
that's not true i watch like everything
aside from Bravo like I really like
scripted TV
I love scripted TV because I don't know
I've gotten to you into some good shows
lately Royals I got you into Riverdale
let let us not forget but Broyles oh my
god I could talk about Royals forever
they still haven't been renewed for a
fifth season
stop I know I need to know what that
finale man yeah same um are you gonna
watch Sabrina the Teenage Witch I think
so I'll give it I'll give it
chance because I trust Ryder off I trust
him with I would trust him with my life
you would yeah no I think it'll be good
and I think that Kiernan chips sure sure
she's like cute and a good actor
yeah dress I just watched all of Mad Men
so I know her now
oh you know her your friends we're
friends yeah I know everything about her
Sally Draper anyways Gina I hope you
know the divorce is smooth and I just
really don't appreciate this use of our
time is she still gonna be on the show
like now I imagine this like technically
makes her more interesting like but it
was weird anyway her husband was like
living in LA five days a week and then
would come at home to OC on the weekend
so she was like a single mom anyway
weird it was yeah and she had never seen
his place in LA hmm all very fishy and I
called it
next up weird story Nick Carter is under
review by the DEA for sexual assault
allegation a sexual assault case
involving Nick Carter is currently under
review by the LA district attorney a
spokesperson for the LA district
attorney tells enews a case was
presented by the Santa Monica Police
Department on July 31st and Bobbi Nick
Carter
it remains under review the
representative also confirms that the
cases involving a sexual assault
complaint lieutenant solve are three
gasm the Santa Monica Police Department
tells me news I can confirm a victim
came forward to Santa Monica PD in
February 2018 regarding an alleged
sexual misconduct involving mr. Carter
in 2003 following an investigation the
case was presented presented to the LA
DA's office on July 31st 2018 four of
you know additional details are
available weird weird I feel like this
isn't the first time I've heard like
funny business from Lee Carter me too
he's not good news he isn't ever I agree
and why do we know him like what child
show he was a Backstreet Boy right sorry
that's how you know me chess is not a
Milano guys I know Claudia always says
that she like has dementia like I really
have dementia you can't have an iPad
it's Claudia no I haven't you don't
understand like it's so bad like in
Israel like it was so bad I think he
might have been from all the drinking
like it's like her shirt getting to my
head or something but I can't remember
anything so like don't blame me love
made me crazy for sure but you wouldn't
be back to Boise like Stan anyway I
wasn't a stand but like we're like
living for Britney Spears have you been
seeing all this stuff on the in of
course of course I've seen how does
eight year
snitch feel about a year old snitch is
so confused because like when
eight-year-old snitch like I loved
Britney Spears she had the biggest
Britney Spears I was like I forgot her
whole week hello I kissed it every day
before I went to bed like I was obsessed
with her today not even Britney Spears
impersonator at her party I'm convinced
that it was Britney I really thought it
was like him booked so much like her it
was crazy I think it looked like her but
I know it did
watch me I'd say picture for now and who
is that anyway
the fact they get paid to like just look
like someone and the kids believe it and
no and not even that it's like the kids
are so excited there's someone who looks
like a celebrity like it's not like it's
them it's just someone who looks like
that and like it's the weirdest thing
ever but you fell for it
I shall put him in a limo mirror like oh
well then she's like I have to mention
but I remember that yeah who could for
so usually kiss the poster every night
before you went I'm like this was like
when she was like lucky like peach she's
so lucky she's a star yeah she was and
she could move then like she I think
yeah she was like totally with it and
now I just they're two different people
I think I agree like there's there's
this one and then there's this one and
like it's just there's no and I think
this one this new one is ruining this
one yeah because and she needs to stop
working and their tires like go home and
go to sleep she needs to say she has
like a lot of money and she doesn't seem
like she requires like like she doesn't
get her extensions change that often so
literally what are you spending money on
like she could live a small quiet life
yeah and I think she would be so much
happier she just needs to stop like it's
over and she should be happy about that
she had an amazing career she was a
superstar like go to sleep with your hot
let's go to sleep go to sleep what's
that from you know you wouldn't know we
all have size in New York oh why would I
know that cuz its iconic and your
toaster I'm sorry I'm sorry I know the
hands you know the hands the hands one
what's their chest yeah yeah that one I
know what sacrum I'm Dallas
yes very good the speeches you'll be
okay anyways what were you talking about
Oh Nick harder Nick harder than just
being in trouble
be a good man go home to your wife can
you try this right I believe he has a
wife I feel like they had an ego for a
second or they were like we're feet
happy I'm watching Barry Cavallari I've
heard horrible i weirdly have been
because I'm always like available when
it's on ok and it's not horrible it has
potential it's just a little too fake
and stupid for me and the girls are
trying too hard like there's this one
girl who works for Kristen who's a
redhead and like she's trying to be like
the [ __ ] and it's like if you're gonna
be a [ __ ] like you need to have a
really good cause like and will rally
behind ya it was to be a villain but
she's like I'm just picking on this girl
I'm like it's uncomfortable hmm
you know yeah fine so whatever our fifth
and final story is an update from a
story earlier this week because we
reported that Apple was on its way to
hitting the one trillion mark and Apple
has hit the one trillion mark the first
US company in history that's so crazy
reach the mark on Thursday when Cher's
hit two hundred and seven dollars and
five cents I hope you guys bought chairs
when we told you to insider-trading over
here on the morning totes did you buy a
share no I don't even know how to like
do code without the shares we're
probably super expensive last week - yes
but then they got more expensive so
right I don't I don't know what if
everyone sells their chairs now and
Apple goes back below one trillion but
so crazy though is that like I was just
saying this before it's like everyone's
always like no Apple talks like Samsung
is ready to go but like clearly not and
Samsung's like blow up in your ear only
people with Samsung say that except
eventually I'm like kind of I'm getting
pissed with Apple Claudie and I were
talking about maybe a new phone you guys
have no respect they are customer
service like yeah they help you but like
they just are yeah they have no respect
like all the new charger upgrades it's -
how annoying it is I okay this was my
whole summer my phone was always dying
but I was always listening to music and
it was like it's the same plug now and
like I can't get air pods because I'm
gonna lose them because I'm a
responsible so it's like what do I do
I can't listen in charge at the same
time so I've sacrificed one for the
other when it used to be that you could
do both get you a phone that I need both
but it's their way of making me get air
pods but now I'm not paying $150 to have
to pay $150 in two weeks when I lose
them totally I actually might get air
pods soon they seem great
for a massage I'm always tangled in
cords when I'm listening to music during
massage scams in Israel and bought fake
ear pods and like you're such a sucker
sound quality was so bad it was $20 so
like it was fine that likes 20 hours had
come to a real pair yeah well we should
start a GoFundMe to get Snitch a pair of
ear pods I could get them but then I'll
lose them so again I need I need I don't
think you will it's like when you got a
pair of expensive sunglasses and you
don't lose them because like but like
that's just another thing to have a bit
about I don't know singe I think I think
you should have messed big you know I'm
gonna get them first because I actually
need them okay let me know like Zach has
that mean he loves them but he's so
gadgety like he would totally we're not
like that no but it really is nice not
to have all those wires especially like
if you're on a run when they fall out I
don't think so I think then they tuck in
nicely okay whatever
anyways those are the past five stories
that you needed to know this morning
we're gonna bring out Nastia Liukin and
just get her thoughts on being so
talented and then we will be back with
snitch taking all of your questions
really diving into her summer in Israel
and just like what it means to be a
snitch right because I know that see you
soon
you
you
we are back with Nastia Liukin whose
name is so fun to say you are the
definition of a bursty lasty do you ever
watch the click or read the click books
a personality someone who like their
first name in that last name just
coupled together so nicely well and it's
like six letter I always loved this when
I was like in school it's like six
letters and six letters it's like
perfect rope to it again yeah it sounds
very good like announced on a microphone
at the Olympics happened a lot for you a
few times yeah so as someone who's an
Olympian has so much talent like what is
it like because body and I joke like you
are so talented
you bleed talent and we are here just
talking for an hour but also that takes
Talent I have to say no it really does
like it's a different kind of talent
obviously like flipping and doing stuff
but like being on I think it feel like
people don't realize like how difficult
it actually is to like have a
personality and be this persona and no
I'm serious I'm not just trying to like
I quit Johnny please even I love you
guys but it really does like it's I
think it's harder than it looks and I
feel like I realized that since I
started commentating and broadcasting
like you think it's so easy just to talk
and it's not oh yeah always
and some days are harder than others
absolutely wake up and you're just like
I don't know how I'm gonna do this right
and I just I can't find the word like
literally yesterday we were talking
about Lisa written on the show and it
took me like eight hours to figure out
what word I was trying to say on the
show which is that she's a pacifist just
wanted to get that out there like
someone who's both peaceful yes
do you watch housewives you're actually
very busy okay
I'm like I I do like like reality TV
like the Kardashians like but I don't
watch anything like consistently because
I am never consistently in one place
right barring or like whatever yeah it's
hard to watch your shows on the road and
you are on the road a lot a lot so you
have a very busy life how has it been
transitioning from the gymnastics world
which is very routine into what you're
doing now entrepreneurial and just being
an influencer yeah I think that was like
the heart like transitions in general or
just hard regardless of like what kind
of transit
you know of whether you're going from
high school to college or then like
graduating from college and just going
into real life or for me it was like
gymnastics like defined who I was as a
person for 22 years and so it was like
transitioning out of that I was like Who
am I like I I have no idea who I am
I don't know what I like to do I don't
know how to eat I don't know how to work
out I don't know how to like do anything
because first of all I was always kind
of told what to do and then it was like
I didn't have that like coach in my life
anymore so I had to figure it out and
and I think both like physically it was
hard but like mentally challenging too
because my whole life was always like
not stealing in the Olympic gymnast you
know and then it was like wait but who's
just Nastya like I had no idea so it was
like kind of depressing for a while like
yeah well you've come out the other end
and it seemed it's like everything is
fabulous you and Shaun are best friends
and you guys are like relationship goals
I tried to see you in Nashville yeah so
sad thanks for at CMA fest when we were
there and but you were like yeah on the
highway yes see you guys have the best
time it was so fun so Shaun and her
husband live in Nashville full-time and
so obviously they're traveling a lot too
but yeah so it was like so fun to be
able to go and just have like a fun
weekend and then also CMI fest was fun
that's so fun were you guys this close
when you were competing as well so it's
really funny because everyone asks this
all the time now I'm like we don't we hi
guys never really like told the story
but so we were like best friends before
the Olympics leading up to the Olympics
like because I feel like we were so
similar as people and just like as
athletes like we went to sleep early we
like wrote wrote in our journals we like
to read like we were so focused and we
had that same goal and so I think like
we were roommates at the Olympics and so
going to sleep the night before the
all-around finals and we just like
literally like we're in our beds like
just like looked at each other and then
just like turning around and like one to
sleep and it was just like that's so
intense I always wonder like at the
Olympics like how people like how do you
sleep at how do you just like walk
around like how do you just like act
like normal and everything like it's
just this there's so much on your mind
there's so much I think like going to
sleep for us was obviously the night
before like the competitions was a
little bit more challenging but we were
there for about a month so like a few
weeks of training before and like
getting adjusted to the time zone and
everything but I think you're so
exhausted also because we train seven
hours a day every single day we didn't
have a single day off and so we were
like ready to go to sleep every night um
but yeah I mean I think for us it was
like we were best friends and then you
know she was 16 and I was 18 but like we
were both like probably maturity wise
and just like experienced when I was
like 5 years younger than that because
like our life was just gymnastics and so
I think it was really everybody else on
the outside like pitting us against each
other after they home fake so it was
like you know friends since like shun
got this when I got this Shan Sun means
no stars not she's doing this like she
got this deal she got this deal and then
it was just like oh my god like we
should I guess like we have to compete
against each other and then I became
this like weird thing and then it was
just like everyone else saying that you
know like we don't get along and it was
like wait but we do but then we started
believing that and so it just became to
this point it that lasted for eight
years so like we didn't speak to each
other basically for eight years which is
insane we didn't have each other's
numbers because we both got new numbers
and like didn't give each other and so
we would sometimes I go to events where
like we would both show up and we'd be
like like rolling our eyes and like do
they like so fake like hey like good to
see you how are you and then walk away
and just be like and then the same thing
like every interview like people would
always ask like how shot like whatever
and we're just like she's great like
yeah we're just so busy we don't see
each other and like we had the same
standard answer and that we like joke
about it but so how did you guys
reconnect so it was actually her husband
and my fiance because like we would both
tell them like about like and it was
really really funny because we wouldn't
follow each other on Instagram but like
we would stalk each other's Instagram oh
my god
like you're just like not following you
but I'm gonna look at all your
everywhere you're called a lurker yeah
and so so I was in New York I was living
here going to school and I was sitting
down at Gemma
I like remember this yeah what a good
place to rekindle well yeah so I was
sitting then with the New York Times
having an interview and he literally
asked me about Sean and I was just kind
of like she's great like you know like
whatever and then he's like well her
weddings coming up like are you gonna be
there well I wasn't invited at the time
and I was just like oh I'm not sure like
you know I'm so busy and like I don't
know yeah like meet a while and just
like didn't get the invite thanks John
and and then he got up excused himself
to get up to use the restroom and I just
like opened my phone and I like wet in
my email and I had like an email from
her that was this long and I was just
like like literally had no words and she
was basically like look like this is so
stupid like it's been eight years
there's like it shouldn't be this way we
have so much in common we we are best
friends like we just let so many people
get you know in the way basically and
and she was like Andrew her husband
she's like Andrew actually made me write
this email and then I was so mad because
I was like I sent it to my fiancee right
away like send him a screenshot and she
was like he was like I've told you to do
this for like years now like she was the
bigger person and I was like yeah and
then the guy came back and I was just
like so about Sean like we're great no
and then we started talking again and we
hadn't met I had never met Andrew she
had never met Matt and she was like you
know and it would mean so much to us if
you guys would be at our wedding so it
was like two months later and we went to
the wedding and like everyone met for
like the first time and yeah it's it's
so weird like your whole story is like
people still don't get it because people
think like for eight years like we
actually hated each other where we
didn't it was just like I don't even
know how to explain it like I don't know
what happened
it was just like something happened
where we like just didn't I don't know
and then we are best friends now which
like people also can't comprehend
they're just like what happened we
actually live together in LA
um because like my main houses in Boston
hers is in Nashville but we spend so
much time in LA and so we were both
looking for one bedrooms like just
because we were staying in hotels so
often then we like the four of us look
to each other and we like wait would
this be the worst idea ever
or like the greatest idea ever and so we
ended up getting a place together and we
we barely overlap just because of our
schedules but then when we're there
together it's like fun like we have like
game nights and post mates and like we
obviously have so many of the same
interests or like Beach days or go work
out or something so yeah that's just
what do you worry what a story ups and
down for a while the wedding your fiance
we got a lot of questions for you
because people saw you without your ring
on Instagram so of course the rumors
start flying yeah but you are very much
still engaged yeah you are wearing your
ring today yes I am no I I take my ring
I don't know like I nice like you're
you're obviously I started taking my
ring off more often now so I understand
like yesterday on the show I forgot to
wear it yeah yeah and like when I work
out or at the beach like I just like
don't wear it so yeah I mean there's
always times that I don't but yeah we're
just everyone has you know obviously
been our cement like a wedding day and
we're just so busy like we have a
business together which is amazing we
have the grander summit coming up that
we're planning in Boston which we're
super excited about and and just like
we're just not in a rush to get married
I mean we live together like we work
together like everything like eventually
you know obviously that's the plan
but um yeah how did you guys meet we
actually met here in New York well I was
going to school at NYU at a mutual
friends engagement party that's a great
worry is because I was living here in
New York for a few years and when I
moved here I was 23 so I grew up in
Texas and so like all my friends were
like
married and on their second and third
kid and I was like I don't even have a
boyfriend oh my god and so I like
frantically it was like oh my god I need
to find a husband I like started trying
to meet people and like go on dates and
I was like people are just like guys
like it's already in New York it's so I
mean it's difficult anywhere but like
especially in New York and so I was like
I finally like I think two years and I
was just like you know what like focus
on yourself focus on your career like I
don't want a boyfriend right now and
literally that weekend I met him and I
was just like literally like right when
I am I
yeah I was just like I knew also a fun
fact about you you were in our favorite
movie ticket yeah with that was filming
that as fun as it seems first of all I
was like in that ugly awkward phase of
my life where I had braces but like you
know when you get braces so I never had
a gap in my teeth but then I like the
braces pulled them apart and so for me I
was just like I don't even look like
myself like and then I had I got the
clear braces because like my parents
were like you can't get because I was
like I'm gonna get colors and they're
like absolutely not like you're getting
clear and then like I just like I hadn't
grown into my but like I just was so
awkward and so weird you could not tell
ya I would never know that no yes you
can like watch it back maybe I'll see
but then you were like the veteran champ
and you're like like it was just it was
an honor for them to have you in their
movie Thanks well it was so much fun it
was interesting because you know I think
for like the directors and producers
like they didn't realize when I was
doing my routines and my skills like my
dad who was my coach he was there and he
had to they kept saying like okay again
again again like as you would just do
like a line or like you know another
take but it was like they would have me
be doing full routines and after like
ten full like borrowed teams my dad was
like okay so just so you know like
that's really really difficult and
they're like oh my god it is like it she
just makes it look so easy we didn't
realize and he was like yeah she
normally does three a day like when
she's training for the Olympics
she's done ten and like we're on a movie
side and and so they were like I'm we're
so sorry and so he they then they like
really wanted to be like educated more
about gymnastics and like Jeff Bridges
was you know in the movie and so he was
asking my dad for advice of like okay
what would you actually do like when the
gymnast lands like yeah tell me how to
act tell me what to say so it was cool
because they got to learn you know about
gymnastics but then I got to learn like
about the acting world yeah it's a great
movie and then be so fun just like have
to watch back my god yeah I think at the
time I think it was like 14 and it's
just like to be in a movie and I think
not not to like say it's like iconic but
I feel like there hasn't been like
another gymnast icon so it's like it's
like the bring it on of gymnastics yeah
I think they intended for it to be and
it was yeah they'll and yes it was fun
we're gonna take some questions for you
because the USA Gymnastics has been in
the news a lot lately and you were at
the ESPYs which was a powerful moment
for women in gymnastics and what was it
like to be there watching this woman on
stage I think even just like thinking
about it now like it it was hard being
there and I wasn't even like on the
stage but so many of those women are you
know my friends and my teammates and he
was actually my doctor ever since I was
12 as well and I am so lucky that I
wasn't abused but it also it hits me in
a way and it like I still feel it
because it's like first of all you trust
I trusted him for over 10 years of my
life like he was like the go-to doctor
we had him on speed dial just because
like as a gymnast and like especially
for me I wasn't really that strong and
powerful I was a little bit more like
fragile and so we like always like we're
calling him basically being like okay
now her back hurts okay now this hurts
you know like what do we do and my dad
trusted him like you know with his own
daughter so it's like that just shows
like how like it was like we had no idea
and the first thing like when this
started coming out our entire Olympic
team in 2008 we have a group chat and we
all texted each other and we were like
is everybody okay
like was anybody affected and none of us
were on my Olympic team so it was just
it was so hard I think to even
comprehend because the guy that I knew
was not that disgusting monster you know
what I mean and so I think it took a lot
of time for me to process what was
actually happening and and yeah and so
just like I'm so proud of like being at
the ESPYs and seeing like I knew there
was so many women affected but when you
see 147 young women on the stage and
you're like in the theater and like the
entire room is just up on their feet it
was such a powerful moment and I think
you realize like the magnitude of it all
because when you read about it and you
know like yes it was like it's awful to
read about and know like how many women
were abused but at the same time when
you actually see them in person all
together and like in you know they're
the first to say like they've created
this army you know of sisters and
survivors and it's just like it's it's
so inspiring yet like awful at the same
time but I'm hopeful that you know their
courage and their bravery to come
forward is now helping others you know
that maybe it wasn't by him but somebody
else or something to at least have that
courage to speak up so definitely spoken
about that moment and just the whole
story at length on this show and I felt
like a nice way to move forward while
still like recognizing how terrible it
was so an alley race Minh is a champion
mad ass like we love her and what's
really crazy is she's in the news so
positively but then also her
ex-boyfriend is on The Bachelorette
do you watch yes how does she feel about
him being on the I have a doctor about
that I feel like you know she has more
important things don't worry I met him a
few times while they were dating and
what sort of vibe I feel like when I met
him he was different than what I'm
seeing on TV but you know I guess who
who isn't when they go on that show as a
contestant I don't know like I don't
know I have a lot of like good
girlfriends that were on the show
Rachel Lindsay for instance by the way
I've heard love you can't wait to me if
she's coming to our summit and she said
she's watching today so um hi they great
we love her yeah and and so you know and
Laura it's not like I've so for me it's
like I am NOT judgmental at all but also
I yeah it's it's very interesting the
way that that all kind of panned out
yeah it's pretty sure it's really love
him on the show but when you think about
just his trajectories it's a stream yeah
and like just timing of things I was
Sean the one who introduced them yes so
like made a video that he wanted to meet
her
yes like Andrew Sean's husband and him
we're playing for the Raiders at the
same time while Sean and I were in Rio
we were both working Ali was obviously
competing and yeah Sean you know Ali had
been asking like both you know me and my
fiance like if we had single guy friends
and the same for Sean and I was like no
all my friends are like you know taking
you know whatever married or engaged or
dating and so yeah I guess Sean kind of
set that whole thing up and she
obviously feels a little bad but you
made him like yeah no it's it's really
so crazy
also another crazy story I was in the
news is Margo love Simone biles okay
this wasn't even really in the new I'm
obsessed with Mobile it was more like
more salacious impatient insane like
just everything about her like I'm I'm
just I'm obsessive first of all like
just not human
yeah like I her body as I can say and
like she like has like a 20 pack and it
was just like one
like a week ago if I can make a picture
I was like I literally think I commented
I'm like hi can I have one of your 2001
Muslims crazy anyways if this wasn't
even the news it's just like social
media is like banter but like apparently
at the classic yeah I was commentating
it was yes it was like there was some
drama between Simone biles and Morgan
yeah hurt or something cuz like Morgan
heard they posted like a finn-style like
so weird like a whole thing but it's a
you don't mess with Simone biles like
I'm Finster like the weirdest thing ever
i yeah
I'm not gonna comment much about that
but it's definitely hard cuz I feel like
I don't know both sides of the story I
only know one side of the story but um
yeah first of all I just feel like it's
it's important to respect you know both
sides I think both are you know when you
come in and you haven't been competing
for that many years it's hard to come
back and like I was kind of in her shoes
you know after 2008 when I came back and
I was like I didn't really know the
girls because when you take time away
like a new crop of girls comes up but at
the same time she's great like like
there's she's the greatest gymnast of
all time like hands down and you know
but I'm sure for the new crop of girls
it's challenging because like she's was
there time and you know they kind of
wanted that but at the same time gotta
respect respect each other that's all
I'm gonna say yeah and I feel like for
us like going back and I know Simone
kind of said that too like they're so
cool they're Olympic teams are so close
and it's it's so cool what the Olympics
does like for like me like going back
and knowing that I have like these other
five friends that I'll be connected with
and bonded with for the rest of my life
no matter what like Alicia just had her
second baby Chelsea has kids you know
Sam Brigitte our Sam's in LA and working
Bridget's working and in Sean and I are
like all over the place and you know so
it's it's hard but at the same time it's
like respect each other um and and cheer
for each other you're on the same team
yeah yeah and so I'm hoping that they
can
solve it and figure it out because it's
gonna be a long two years it's not yeah
yeah you Tokyo so very exciting well
thank you so much for joining us you're
taking measures so much good keep up the
great work and we will be back in a jiff
where can everyone follow you at Nastia
Liukin on Facebook Instagram and Twitter
perfection you soon
you
we are back yes oh yeah just snitch and
I and it's just so crazy when you have
an Olympian here and then and then you
don't and then you have a snitch though
and then you have a cinch pretty well
yeah almost the same because it takes a
lot to be a smidge it does I just want
to move my mic over so you are back from
Israel and we have so many questions for
you keep ever really missed you I know
like the questions were wild I'm not
gonna lie your sisters missed you a lot
I miss my sisters a lot who do you think
missed more us miss you or you missed us
sorry guys I just have to readjust um
I think you guys any more dance like I
miss you so much like I was off on the
adventure do you know what I mean right
yeah you were busy and I was just home
like counting down the days until you
came back right I don't think you were
doing that but and also not only is she
a snitch and our co-host she is our new
intern
I know congratulations on the new job I
have to wake up it the alien girls would
kill for the sharp snitch so you better
take it straight I am am I getting paid
uh it's psychological income okay really
you can't really put a price on it
anyways we're so happy that you're here
um something that I really need to talk
to you about and talking to nacio
reminded me is Colton under one because
okay
obviously the gymnastics community
doesn't have much respect for him but he
has they shouldn't they [ __ ] to that as
they shouldn't like they should not he
shouldn't be tarnishing the gymnastics
name but for us we're just regular
people right and we have a big crush on
him
mm-hmm and I have a crush on him like
for you like when I watch the show a
sack I'm like how do you feel about your
new brother-in-law so if you don't say
that I get I mean I say weirder things
mostly that's actually a normal thing
for me to say when it cools him where
The Bachelor would you go on would you
apply like I'll I'd say yeah but like
ideally no like I couldn't handle going
on the bastard from being on it's like
now they like I'm actually early handle
the toes yeah like now that I'm actually
of age and like now ever like I was
always like when I turned 21 my own
bachelor everyone's like telling me to
go on it like I'm sorry I'm not
I really couldn't handle it like hey
like I just think I'd get really fat and
like I wouldn't be able to handle like
seeing myself I gotta drink all the tiny
lay by the pool I'd be just like Israel
right but I'm on TV with a million
Patti girls who like are out for blood
and like I just like I'm out for blood
like not like that do you know what I
mean I understand you're just you're too
nice for the show yeah makes sense but I
guess like it's if times get tough for
you and you're like wow what should they
do with my life just go on The Bachelor
and like me coming in you'll have that's
a good option for you for like the next
four years
okay great after 25 like you're a little
old no no no you're a little old for the
batch um okay that's good to know
we have so many questions for you like
I'm nervous too much new rapid-fire
we're gonna do rapid-fire snitcher ii a
lot of questions that I asked you
yesterday or when I saw you when you
came home from Israel like what was the
peak in the pit of your trip okay so
like I have no clear answer and it's
like so lame but like my peak was like
everything but like some things would
just be like when I went to a lot like
it was so crazy boat trip my boat like
really fun so fun like I never go tubing
in Israel like the fact that I'm alive
in here is just wild like you know
understand they put like you know like
in camp and you have those two tubes you
have a tube it's just like that you lay
on and they take you're on a boat so we
put two at the same time like there's a
one group and one group and we were
going at the same time so is like bumper
cars like on the water and he was going
so fast I don't even think he looked
back once to see if we were alive and
well like I was making noises I could
you know and like I just like making
like weirdest noises like coming out of
my mouth like laughing so hard but like
also screaming and really scared like
kind of crying like so scary but like so
happy I did it so fine I'm never gonna
do it again but like then we'd like to
news crews and it's just so crazy like
the water was like I've seen the
Caribbean water but this was like blue
like royal blue like your eyes used to
you know like eyes are like this color
it's like deep blues crazy it's like I'm
in the middle of a Mediterranean Sea I'd
like each if not my right Jordan on my
left I'm in the middle like in a lodge
right Jordan on my left snitch in the
middle just like what like how am I here
right now like it's just like it was
wild so like it was and it was also
really fun and so that was probably a
peak and just like the whole thing it's
a home and - what was the pit pit
what was my pit I don't know probably
just like I'd it's just like honestly
really nope it's I cried to do a pit it
just be like I like felt fat all the
time that's just a pit of life yeah
what is the best advice advice that
you've received from your sister I saw
this question and like no offense but I
don't like get it like I get advice
dreams like oh what do i do like
specifics yeah but it's like life
advice like you don't give me like a
mantra like you know I just gave you
good advice like if things get rough go
on The Bachelor okay that sounds like
good the best advice that sister's ever
given me what is the thing about America
that you missed most while you were in
Israel manicures manicures are really
hard to come by there and you know what
I told you that was gonna be when you
were like I'll just kind of man here
when I get to I think you think and even
when I like went to a nail place like it
was so so bad and then to explore I left
I found some American girl who like does
manicures like in her apartment which
was really scary but apparently it's
like just a thing that they do in Israel
and he was unbelievable gentleman here
and like I wish I had known in the
beginning but that and wax is my friend
got a wax and she was bruised go bruised
go do you guys call her that do you use
some of the inside skinny jokes with
your friends yeah like what my friends a
lot of like started calling me snitch
towards the end of the summer like we
wrote each other bus notes and she wrote
like dear snitch oh that's cute yeah
that's really cute
I I like her already I haven't met her
guy you would love her yeah cool
KY Lana which celebrity would fit in
best with you and your sisters mastiha I
feel like a lot of a lot of Sighs I feel
like it's not really that hard to fit in
with us like you just need to have a big
personality I feel like the Kardashians
like okay boys like family friends we
could be a hundred but there is just
like a little bit older than us but we
have old so we do it's not you but you
were modeling in Israel oh god yeah what
were you doing okay like it was it was a
joke I mean it wasn't a joke I did model
bullying it was like didn't you
they actually sent me a a forgot about
it like a $40 ASOS card she was mad if
right anyway my friend Rebecca are like
we're all interning and still the one
she was interning for was like some app
that liked it I don't know what in
clueless they like put clothes on your
body that thing kind of like that and
they needed like bodies and models to do
it's like we all just did it and they
did like your hair and makeup and it was
fun and like we took pictures and so I
could post it exudes larious so where
can we find these photo I mean I have no
idea I'm not showing you well now
there's one like we got the one yeah we
got a guest card for today
right where were you staying in Israel
what city were you in I was in Tel Aviv
and I like did a program so they set us
up with housing and all this stuff
that's cool so if someone who has never
been to Israel like what would you
suggest that they do
if they're planning a trip like for
their first time they're not going on
like birthright I think birthrights a
nice way to break the seal yes and no
birthright is like a great way to get to
know the land but like it's very fun you
all week to like have fun it's very
Museum II like you don't get to like see
the vibrant life they let you out one
night yeah like everyone always like
messages like wow I had no idea that
Israel so it was like it smells like so
much more lit than like any place I've
ever been but like I would just say like
I would say do like a couple days in
Jerusalem so you can get that feeling of
like spirituality like you got to get
that in there
and you should do that first first cuz
then you go to Tel Aviv in like you [ __ ]
[ __ ] up and like you just likes today
one of the hotels like on Gordon Beach
and then you just like go like they have
unreal bars like their bars are so fun
they're like clubs but then you also
have the clubs at the port which are so
fun like just to let you know you know
you should do what you should do like a
blog post like with your Israeli
suggestion or nice
what's this Michi's thing you've ever
done I think you can answer that I just
have this one example in my mind like
it's not super super smoochy but it's
like textbook snitch so one time at
Shabbat like we always play music from
the Alexa and everybody like tells Alexa
like something different Alexa is like
working so hard we never listen to like
more than 30 seconds of one song yeah
and so snitch was like and this is for
you guys with Alexis at home Alexa play
greatest showmen soundtrack so she plays
it knowing that someone's gonna change
it soon she sneakily puts Alexa on mute
so when anyone else went to say they
just thought Alexa was wasn't listening
to him and we got to listen to greatest
showmen for the whole night honestly it
was so small because it was smart and it
was snitchy schnitz gisele what was your
job in Israel what were you doing there
what was your purpose I was a content
creator for a media company and in
Israel like they really burning toast
basically they don't have interns so
like you're on the same playing field as
them like they like just it's free labor
literally so like they just like give
you everything to do so like I was
writing articles for all their websites
but then I was also like I started nine
of their social media accounts on
Instagram and Facebook
I was busy so like I was just doing all
that and did you enjoy it
I did did it help you determine what you
want to do yeah I would like want to do
that like social media and whatever and
like toastiness yeah yeah yeah for real
ah did you meet any cute boys
uh yeah did you find any new hangover
cures no I really didn't get hungover in
Israel which is so crazy exactly the
second I drink here and we're just gonna
be done yeah sometimes like being in the
Sun really helps and also like not
stopping drinking no bright it just
seems like you did a lot of it did who
do you miss more the sisters or Theo the
sisters
you should think long and hard about it
I just said the sisters you're such a
liar you're such a [ __ ] liar Camille
that one is from Camille Grammer there's
an intro for the toast you need to know
these things
study up um how often did you work out
in Israel and then typically how often
does body by Snitch work out in America
okay so like there was I was there for
two months for one month I was going to
the gym everyday and it was really
annoying I know I felt it and then like
I was like you know I only got a one
month like membership and like I was
like I'm not gonna renew you so like I
just did it and so then like so I think
I was a big reason why I didn't gain
weight but then like the last few weeks
I was just eating what I wanted and so I
think if I started that way I would have
beat much punji right now yeah but I was
like what everyone lost weight in the
first month and yeah just like gained it
back yeah yeah you're the same is the
same which is a great way to go and then
here like when I'm in the swing of
things right now like I worked out
yesterday and like I died like I'm
having a hard time like adjusting to
that but usually it's like three to four
times a week I would say that's pretty
good and what's your go-to healthy snack
hmm probably string cheese me too cheese
string cheese string what's your
favorite kind of cheese drink Polly oh
interesting you know what I've been
loving the wait why I hate them I hate
them
oh my god I love them the only thing is
they change the packaging recently they
went cheaper and like they're really
hard to open now I realized and it's
like I don't like the Weight Watchers
ones but they are less calories I think
I think they're 50 versus 80 okay
so tiny so you have to toast a lot while
you were I did while you were gone
because you were working and you
understood the importance of the toast
right but it was on at 5:30 for me so I
wasn't even working that was what I left
no she was one of your sisters to watch
it yeah I mean what's your favorite
episode no but of the ones he watch I'm
Tara path Derrick path was that not
hilarious like I was like I was just
like this the whole time yeah
you listen to the NT podcast oh my did I
ever like are you kidding yeah I did and
like I was like I was drunk that night
when it came out and I got home at like
3:00 in the morning like drunk in my bed
put my headphones in and like was
listening to it I had to be listen to it
the next morning cuz I didn't remember
it but recommitment was there that's
always so hard so now that you're home
and you're really focusing on being an
intern for the most prestigious morning
show while you also run your side
business of body by snitch right where
do you see body by snitch going like
what do you hope for it I really have no
idea like genuinely I'm just gonna keep
doing it and we'll see what happens well
for everyone who doesn't know Margo runs
a fitness Instagram account because she
is so fit you truly are I'm very I'm
very bit like I'm skinny as well but I'm
saying I'm fit she's fit and you should
follow her fitness Jeremy at body by
snitch because you're very very
relatable you keep it real I do keep it
real you post a salads but then you also
pose as and make their closes Lucy the
McDonald's Post from Israel I'm so
jealous
yeah how many times did you have kosher
McDonald's two or three but there was
one night it's actually a great story
one night me and my friend were out and
we were just like I'm over it
so we went in the port there was a
McDonald's there so we went and we got
McDonald's and we got like a nine piece
chicken nugget and fries
totally normal whatever just meet it and
we're like we're so hungry right so we
get the 12 piece and a burger and both
come with fries we had 21 chicken
McNuggets and a burger and fries this
whole fish total total okay like stiff
so you had ten and a half chicken and
half a burger and a [ __ ] ton of fries
that's disgusting and I had did not
being delicious and I have dinner I'm so
hungry
me too are you ready to go have lunch
I'm starving okay guys we are out of
time for today but Snitch will be
interning for this show for the rest of
time for the positive time okay cool yes
and so she'll be popping in and out if
you guys have questions for her if we
need to hear from her we need fitness
tips like she'll be here so say hello
say hello and say goodbye because it is
Friday and we're done and we're gonna go
hey thank you guys for tuning in we love
you follow at the morning toast at
Jackie no problem Adam or gosh or Emma
guys another activity
Norton goodbye
you